long ago humans realize that living
things are made of cells moving
replicating blobs of water which when
arranged just right produce a bigger
blob that moves and replicates and makes
youtube videos and then a biologist
boarded a boat called the Beagle to
better understand the beaks of birds he
noticed that islands rich with seeds
were home to short beak birds and where
fish were far and wide so - or beaks and
since birds don't change beaks like
humans and hats he had discovered
natural selection but this study of how
incredible living organisms emerged from
very simple microscopic things is really
a story of economics
wherever resources are limited the same
basic laws apply whether in ants plants
or fortune 500 companies living
organisms are running economic
simulations that can help answer some of
our biggest questions this is the
biology of business the goal of a
business like any organism is to stay
alive yet they'll set up camp even in
the darkest dirtiest places so why live
in the extreme cold and why buy and sell
human organs when there's easier money
to be made because economic laws make
these places desirable if there are too
many penguins they starve and recover
until a sustainable number is reached in
extreme environments that number is very
low so it might suck to live in the
Antarctic
but there's so little competition that
is worth adapting and as long as there's
demand for corrupt and distasteful
services so too will businesses be
willing to provide them that's because
prices naturally rise until someone will
make a deal and someone always will and
in every environment organisms have
different strategies for survival rats
and mice are really just genetic batons
passing on their genes as quickly as
possible to many children no need for
private rat school they play the numbers
game betting that at least one will be
successful
elephants prefer to invest in just a few
children which they just stayed for
nearly two years and companies are no
different many see Amazon as
disorganized this week announcing a
phone designed for no one and next a
button for buying pop-tarts and others
think Apple is too slow at entering
markets and adding features putting
their eggs in so few baskets
but these aren't failures of management
just different strategies for survival
Amazon takes the mouse approach of
trying a bunch of products
hopes that some will succeed Apple is
the elephant investing very heavily and
only a few products which are late to
enter the market but surely not all
strategies are equally efficient
so which organism will win the game of
evolution and what does the perfect
business look like well there's no
finale to evolution because as the
environment changes so too does natural
selection and the features that make it
good species in one environment are
detrimental in another there will
probably never be a single all-powerful
by and large corporation because
different markets require different
adaptations it's easy to think of
evolution as a force that needs no
controlling that better businesses and
species will thrive naturally but
evolution is blind to all but one fact
does this gene increase or decrease the
chance that his hosts will reproduce it
doesn't know if it also hurts the group
as a whole
Irish elk are a good example bigger
antlers attracted more mates which began
an evolutionary arms race of all antlers
getting bigger but what evolution didn't
know was how much of a burden these huge
antlers would become every elk would be
better off if all their antlers were
half as big but no individual elk could
do so and still find a mate likewise
market forces can shape businesses in a
way that hurts everyone but no
individual business could resist and
stay competitive all of this means that
you are guided by markets like ants are
guided by evolution but it also means we
have millions of accidental economic
experiments in nature just waiting to be
explored as much as I love reading I'm
always frustrated by how little content
can be in such a large book authors are
pressured to write longer books so they
take their ideas and add as much fluff
as possible and even a shorter book can
be hard to get through if you're a busy
person but this video is sponsored by
blinka an app that takes the key
insights of thousands of non-fiction
books and condenses them into a few
minutes reading or listening
it's like hiring someone to read books
for you and report back what's important
whenever you're ready in the time it
takes to read one full book you could be
getting all the important parts of many
and my favorite part is that blinkers
doesn't make you pay for each book a
single subscription gives you access to
as many books as you want if you're
already a heavy reader
blink is does a great way to browse a
book before committing to it and in case
you're not sure where to start let me
recommend so you've been publicly shamed
by Jon Ronson go to Glinka calm slash
poly matter to make 2018 the year you
read more you can get 20% off your first
year or try it completely free if you're
not sure